- Hello everybody,
it's Gary Veynerchuk
and this is episode 326
of the Ask Gary Vee Show.
I'm super excited to have
Tilman Fertitta here with me.
I'm gonna let him introduce himself.
But we are taking
questions on Facebook today
and so let's just get right into it.
Tilman thank you for being on.
- Hey it's exciting to be here, Gary.
Everybody wants to come and
be on the Gary Vee show.
(laughter)
- [Gary] I appreciate that.
So Tilman for the group
that's watching right now
or listening that
doesn't know who you are,
I'm a big fan of the origin stories.
So why don't you tell everybody
A, how you currently position yourself
because one thing I
adore about you from afar
is you got your hands in
a lot of different stuff.
It's that kind of entrepreneurial mindset
that I can attest to that.
I understand it.
So when somebody neat sits down with you
and doesn't know who you are,
they're like, what do you do?
How do you answer it?
- (laughs) That's really funny.
That doesn't happen that often.
But when it does I just say,
you know I'm just trying
to make a few dollars.
I have a few little businesses
and my main business is a
company called Landry's.
It's about 600 restaurants.
And Landry's owns everything from
Mastro's to Martin's to
Rainforest to Bubba Gump
to Saltgrass to Oceanaire to Dos Caminos
to Bill's Burgers and on and on and on.
There's like 50 brands.
- [Gary] How many?
5-0.
- Yeah about 50 brands
and over 500 restaurants.
And then the five Golden
Nugget casinos are mine.
And then aquariums,
amusement parks, Catch,
and then I have this little sports team
called the Houston Rockets.
And I do that on the
side when I'm not busy.
- (laughs) So let's take
it all the way back.
Where were you born?
What kind of kid were you?
- (Tilman) I was born in Galveston, Texas.
It's a BOI.
And I was never the
smartest kid in the class.
I can honestly tell you that.
And I can remember a
teacher telling me once,
you know Mr. Fertitta we
know you have leadership
abilities but we wish you would
lead in the right direction.
- [Gary] Look at this.
I don't know how bad you were at school,
but this is probably my pride and joy,
my report card.
It's pretty fuckin' ugly.
It is a doozy.
As you're getting your
glasses why don't I,
oh there you go.
- [Tilman] No I've got
to see these grades.
See who was worst,
me or you.
This looks like one of
mine in third grade.
- [Gary] (laughs) This is my high school.
- You know what,
I am going to find...
- [Gary] Look at my class rank.
Look down there. 240 all
the way at the bottom.
243 out of 254.
There were only 11 kids in my school
that were worse than me.
And there's no shot any
of the 11 are alive.
- (Tilman) That is so good.
I just love this because
I wasn't far behind.
And that's what's
amazing is I've talked to
entrepreneurs,
we're given a different ability
and it's a god-given ability and we just
know how to do it.
- [Gary] Knowing that
you've been around sport,
do you view entrepreneurs
like athletes that way?
Like James Hardin was given a gift.
That's obvious to a lot of people.
It's a little less obvious
where you're going with this
on the entrepreneurial kick
but I couldn't agree with you more.
- Gary I talk about it all the time.
I talk about it in this book
that God gave us all an ability
and he decided,
Tilman I'm not gonna make you a musician.
'Cause I took guitar
lessons for four years
and I still couldn't play a chord.
I'm not gonna let you win a Grammy,
I'm not gonna let you win an Emmy.
We're sure not gonna ever let you
be an NBA all star or be
a professional athlete.
But you know what we're gonna do?
We're gonna give you a good little
business brain where you
know how to make money.
And I realized that when I
was in elementary school.
I would carry my business around.
I wouldn't read a comic
book or do anything.
I was selling candy and
anything else I could
buy and sell in junior high.
In high school I was already
trading the stock market.
In college I was already booking bets.
- I get it.
What did your parents do?
- [Tilman] My dad owned
a seafood restaurant
when I was growing up
and was an entrepreneur.
And there's lots of entrepreneurs in our
family genetic pool on both sides.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- And so definitely it's a gene.
- [Gary] Yes no question.
- Without a doubt.
- [Gary] No question.
- And but I can remember my dad though
after I had my fifth restaurant
and I was making a couple
million dollars a year
saying why do you want to do anymore?
- [Gary] You made it.
- You're making more money,
you have made it.
- By the way I helped build
my dad's one wine store
into a national e-commerce
player in the late 90's.
And everybody in my high
school and my friend group
said I'd made it and I remember
when they would say that
to me at 28, 29, 30, and I left at 34.
It was a family business,
I built it from a three to
a 60 million dollar business
and then I left to start at zero
'cause it was my dad's business.
And that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to give back to my dad.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I was very proud and grateful
for what my parents did for me
but at 29, 30, 31,
my friends were like you made it.
'Cause they would read the articles,
they would hear the numbers.
And I used to laugh,
I'm like they don't even
know that I'm about to
re-start from zero.
- [Tilman] Totally.
- I made it. Like by the
way I feel like I haven't
fuckin' started right now.
- [Tilman] I get up every day
and it's kind of funny.
And I'm a little older than you,
and it's just sport.
- [Gary] It is just sport.
- And when I was 21 I
won my first Cadillac
selling Shaklee Vitamins.
I said when I'm 35 I'm
gonna buy my first jet.
I did.
And on and on and on.
- [Gary] Let me ask you a question.
Have you thought about tangible things?
Like for example,
it doesn't come natural to this day.
I want to buy the New York Jets.
So you've accomplished
something I want to do, right?
But I don't want anything else in between.
But were you somebody who wanted stuff
like Cadillacs, jets, you like that shit?
Or you thought it meant something?
I'm just curious how your brain worked.
- [Tilman] No no, totally.
I mean I had in my brain
that this is what I want.
And I'm gonna try to get
from point a to point b
however I have to do it.
And I hope you're not in
the way 'cause I have to
run over your ass.
- [Gary] I understand.
- But I wanted the
Cadillac, I wanted the...
- [Gary] Can I ask you a deep question?
- [Tilman] Deep.
- Do you think you wanted
that to show the people
that thought you were not going to win
that you were winning as an indicator?
I think about this a lot.
I don't have this great
need to show anybody,
it's unbelievable to me how much I don't
give a fuck if they know
if I'm winning or not.
I'm just obsessed with the process.
However there are many
other things I have.
I'm just always curious with
ones that go along the way,
'cause we're all different in our nuances.
I'm always fascinated by what
did those things represent?
Some people just like stuff.
I'm fascinated by people
who love a car or a jet.
They understand it,
they're like it's got the horse power.
I'm like what the fuck, right?
And there's other people
who need it to be like,
I'm gonna fuckin' show Susan
Thompson in third grade
who didn't go to the dance with me
that she fucked up.
- No I think it was more of the luxury.
And how I wanted to live.
I never had that mentor
and I also never had that
I need to show you so.
It was more in competitiveness with myself
and how I wanted to live.
And I'm proud that I've never
gone through a TSA line.
- [Gary] (laughs) And
what's crazy about that,
this is what I love
about this shit Tilman.
And on the flip side,
I put out so much content
of me being at the airport.
Like I on the flip side love that I limit
my private travel.
And we're doing the same thing.
We're both putting something that we've
subjectively decided is
important on a pedestal.
- [Tilman] No 100%.
- Yeah.
- [Tilman] It's interesting.
- Yeah I mean everyday I'm like,
I'm such a fuckin' idiot.
Time is the only asset
and I'm fucking putzing
around on fuckin' commercial
but then I'm like,
fuck so many people are watching.
They get so much visuals around
private and all this stuff
and I'm still comfortable
like this I like it
and it's a very interesting thing
that I play ping-pong in my head.
- [Tilman] No 'cause even so many
close friends of mine
have always said to me,
are you ever gonna take
me on one of your jets?
I've known you for all these years.
I don't do anything to show off.
It is strictly...
- [Gary] I believe you.
- This is the way I wanna live.
- It's all about how you wanna live.
- What's the least efficient thing you do
that is around how you wanna live?
Like what's something that's silly?
Like I think me flying
commercial is silly.
It's not a good use of my time.
But it's how I want to
live so I understand it.
What is something funny that you do
that doesn't make sense?
- Probably I love being
in Monte Carlo on my yacht
but going shopping at Zara
and coming back to my boat
and laying out to all of my crew that,
look at all these jackets I just bought,
how gorgeous they are
for 18.99 euros each,
that I had six gorgeous
jackets that I only spent
130 euros on and I was proud of myself
I couldn't wait to show my crew.
That's what I'm proud of,
even though I like these nice things,
I love to make a deal and
love to spend money on what I like.
I'll spend money on the big things
but I watch how I spend
it on the little things.
- I understand.
I really do.
So how did your career go?
You sold some stuff,
you won a Cadillac,
you were a good salesman,
gift of gab, charisma.
Conviction.
You know, right?
Determination.
I understand all that shit.
Because your dad had a seafood restaurant,
did you work in that
seafood restaurant as a kid?
- [Tilman] Yeah 100%.
- Learned the craft.
- [Tilman] So I learned how
the restaurant business worked.
Then you go to school,
you get out and I got into
the development business.
I was building homes.
Got into the video game business,
the Pac-Man, Asteroids.
- [Gary] Talk to me about that.
- I just timed it right.
- [Gary] No, no, I mean I don't know this.
I don't know a lot about anything.
So that's why I love having these things.
What did you do with that?
- [Tilman] Back in the
80's you had Asteroids
that came out and it was
the first real video game.
And then it became Defender
and Pac-Man and all of those.
Well I saw that the world was changing
and so I went out and
bought these machines
and started putting them
in restaurants around.
And all of the sudden I
look up and I'm making
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash.
- [Gary] Are you literally
driving your Cadillac around
grabbing buckets of fucking quarters?
- [Tilman] No but I went
out probably in the first,
I can't remember.
But no eventually we
had few trucks doing it.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And all I remember is carrying all these
big bags of quarters and all I know is
I was in high cotton.
I was feeling really good about myself.
And did that for a few years
which gave me the opportunity to start
building homes and little shopping centers
and then I built my first
hotel when I was 26 years old
in my hometown which I still own today.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- And that's kind of the story.
Then the development business came apart,
all the banks failed in the late 80's.
This is a great story and I
talk about it in the book.
I had loans at nine different banks
in the late 80's in Texas.
And this crisis was as bad
as the '08, '09 crisis.
- [Gary] Yeah '87,
Black Friday was horrible.
- [Tilman] That was the,
the world came apart.
Every bank that I did business
with failed before I did.
And so this two million worth of loans,
which was a bunch of money in the 80's,
there was no money to pay.
All of the sudden you
have to make a payment
and there's nobody to make a payment to.
The bank is gone.
The FDIC has shut them
mother fuckers down, okay?
- [Gary] Tilman real quick,
'cause I want you to go back point,
please tell the kids here
how much two million dollars,
give me a number of the way you feel
two million dollars in '87,
what's that equivalent to right now?
- I would probably say 20 million.
You know it would be
like having 20 million.
- [Gary] I apologize,
I always tell my audience,
I'm like my trendsetting
moment in my career
was when I was right about YouTube
but I didn't invest in it.
And then I read when YouTube sold for
$1.7 billion to Google,
I don't know if you remember this
or anybody else in the room,
that sounded like a trillion.
Now companies that don't make any money
are worth a billion.
But at the time,
this is only 2007,
1.7 billion?
It shook me.
- [Tilman] It's a crazy number.
And I'll give you an example.
So basically what happened was
I got a reprieve from the governor, okay?
And so all of the sudden I had five years
to keep growing my business before
the FDIC called me and said,
Mr. Fertitta we have some loans here
we would like to talk to you about.
But by then I'd opened up
a bunch of restaurants,
made a bunch of money.
I walked in and the paid
the FDIC $2 million.
They waived all the interest.
And they said you are the
only person to pay us in full.
But I was rollin' then
and so things were good.
Do you want to wait til that thing goes?
- [Gary] Keep going.
- Doesn't bother you.
- You know what's so,
in 1982 I bought into the
Rockets for $200,000.00.
- [Gary] Is that true?
I didn't know that.
- We paid $10 million for
the Houston Rockets in 1982.
- [Gary] You got 20% for $2 million?
- No no just the small percentage.
- [Gary] I understand,
one more time 'cause I didn't hear it.
- [Tilman] $200,000.00,
20% would have been 2 million.
So I think we also had some debt on it.
I think I owned three or four percent.
Whatever it was.
Okay so I'm a partner in
the Rockets for 10 years.
The owner decides to sell.
The general partner says,
this is becoming a billionaire's game.
Well this is in 1992 and I'm only worth
about 10, 15, million dollars.
Don't get me wrong
that's a bunch of money.
I didn't have the ability
to buy the team by myself.
So I had a partner and we tried to buy it
and I got outbid by a New
Yorker, Les Alexander.
He paid $80 million for this team.
So in 10 years the team
went from being worth
10 million to 80 million, okay?
Now here we go.
25 years later...
- [Gary] Before you finish,
I just want to remind people,
they've heard me say it a lot,
the 1982 NBA Finals in
America was on tape delay.
- [Tilman] It was nothing.
- The league was nothing.
The way you guys think
about hockey right now,
this was below that.
And it's important,
and I'll tell you why it's important.
And the reason I jumped in twice now,
the 2 million, the 20, the league,
you and I have a similarity
as I'm listening.
It's just arbitrage.
It's seeing things just enough
time before somebody else
but then having the
conviction and the gumption
to fuckin' do something.
- 100%.
So think about this,
in 1992 I get outbid for 80 million.
25 years later I don't get the team
so I'm building my company.
So I build,
and that 25 years I grow my
net worth from 10 million
to almost 5 billion, okay?
- [Gary] That's good.
- The Rockets go up for
sale again 25 years later.
I come in with the highest bid,
I was right there.
Most ever paid for a sports
franchise, 2.2 billion.
So in 25 years the value of that team goes
from 80 million to 2.2 billion.
And that's real dollars.
This isn't Monopoly money, okay?
You wire the money.
You pay for it.
- Tilman, were you a big basketball fan?
- This is so unbelievable.
I sit in the same seats today
that I sat in for the last 25 years,
center court.
This is so funny,
after I bought the team
I'm one of the 30 longest
season ticket holders
of the Rockets.
- [Gary] I love you.
- [Tilman] Isn't that amazing?
- Not only is it amazing,
it's literally gonna be
I'm gonna tell this story in 31 years.
I'm gonna clip this.
You know how to clip old shit?
I'm gonna clip this and be like,
I was sitting in this seat,
now I'm here and some new person,
she's sitting in that seat.
I fuckin' understand.
I would kill my children
for the New York Jets.
(laughter)
- You know what?
I would sell my children,
I won't kill 'em,
for the Houston Texans or
the Dallas Cowboys (laughs).
- [Gary] You like both those teams?
You want to own an NFL team,
is that what you're saying?
- I would love to own an NFL team.
- [Gary] As a young kid,
who was your favorite team?
- You know what's kind of funny is...
- [Gary] 'Cause baseball was religion
when you were a kid.
- And I was the biggest
Astros buddy there was.
There was Astros all over.
But what happened was,
you young guys don't know this but...
- [Gary] They don't know shit.
- Ya'll don't know shit.
(laughter)
Ya'll don't know how bad we had it.
You couldn't even watch
the NFL team in Houston
and you lived in Galveston
'cause it was the 50 mile blackout rule.
'Cause they wanted you
to come to the game.
- If they didn't sell out,
they left you out.
That's how the Raiders
and Cowboys and Steelers
became all people's fans
because when they would black you out,
they'd show you one of those three teams.
- [Tilman] Because Dallas was
the next closest team
and remember this,
when do you become a sports fan?
Nine, ten years old.
So I'm nine, ten years old,
that's when the Cowboys start playing the
Green Bay Packers and the Ice Bowls,
and I'm watching them because
the Houston Oilers aren't on TV.
- [Gary] Tilman, as somebody
who's in a market with
two other basketball teams
in the state of Texas
even though it's a big state,
I have an idea for you that I'm gonna do
when I buy the Jets.
When I buy the Jets,
because I hate the Giants
more than anything,
well not more than the Patriots,
but I hate the Giants, right?
When I buy the Jets,
my core marketing strategy
to win the Tri-state area
is on every single person's sixth birthday
I'm gonna send them a Jet's jersey
and personalized messages.
I think you should start
sending six year olds
jerseys in San Antonio and Dallas
of Rocket players.
- [Tilman] Why in the hell
did you tell me this on air
so I couldn't have said that
I'm the smart mother fucker
that came up with this?
(laughter)
Let me be smart please?
- Tilman this is the greatest
strategy I came up with.
Because I have good ideas,
and because I can't execute all of them,
I put them out for free
so that I can own the IP.
- Interesting
- [Gary] Right?
- Interesting, 100%.
- [Gary] Think about all the smart shit,
just getting a sense of you right now.
By the way I'm gonna say this publicly,
I'm not joking I had
no clue you owned the,
I don't know much about a lot of stuff.
I just spend 100% of my
time on the consumer.
I just don't know a lot of stuff.
I just know what customers
are doing at all times.
That's why I don't know
much of other stuff.
That takes a lot of time.
So this gets booked through email,
Matt put us together.
But I know of you of course.
And over the last week I've been with some
fancy different people
like movers and shakers.
The reason I was so excited
to come in here today
is I basically live my life for people
to talk about me behind my back
the way the four people that
I spoke to in the last week
about you talked about you.
- [Tilman] Interesting.
That is interesting.
I don't know if it was good or bad.
- [Gary] It was very good.
It was very good because
what was interesting is
I'm always fascinated by people
that actually know people.
Versus knowing of them.
- [Tilman] Interesting.
- You know my big game in life,
there's plenty of people
with the way I roll,
the cursing, the bravado, the
confidence, the conviction,
especially if I'm putting
pressure on your business,
you're not gonna love me but I care about
what the people that
actually know me say about me
and in that group a couple
of them really know you
and are also very close to me
so they're not gonna bullshit me.
It's really cool.
I like that.
- [Tilman] I appreciate that.
So keep going.
- Well why did you write the book?
- It's really interesting,
about 18 months ago HarperCollins...
- [Gary] My publisher.
- Called me and said,
hey we watch your television
show "Billion Dollar Buyer",
we see you on all the business shows
and you always have these
Tilmanisms and one liners
and we've read all
these articles about you
and how you say,
oh I can see a burnt out light bulb
at one of my restaurants from 40,000 feet,
and they said,
we'd like you to write a book.
Well I always thought somebody would say,
we want you to write a life story book.
And I said I can't do that until I'm older
'cause I'm still doing deals
and I wanna rip some people's ass, okay?
So they said no we want you to...
- [Gary] Do you garage sale?
- [Tilman] Sir?
- Do you ever garage sale?
Do you roll up on a garage sale
and try to buy something for a dollar?
That's bazaar for you, right?
- Not as bazaar as my garage sale.
- But did you?
- Absolutely when I was younger.
- [Gary] I apologize for interrupting,
but you said "rip somebody's ass,"
and I'm like,
I'll give you a story.
I was at the National
Sport's Car Convention.
I gotta talk to you about basketball cards
before we leave,
I see a humongous
arbitrage in sports cards
and you need to go all in.
(laughter)
I'm being dead serious with you.
On the record.
I was at the National
Sports Car Convention
in Chicago in late July this year.
I walked over to some guy's table,
bought a Wayne Gretzky rookie card.
Not in great condition for $220,
I brought it back to my table,
priced it at $260,
an hour later somebody came
over and bought it for $260.
I swear on everything,
that $40.00 arb meant more to me than all
$50 trillion deals I make every day.
- [Tilman] Absolutely.
'Cause that's what we do.
That's like me making the
deal at Zara for all these
jackets on a clothes line.
- [Gary] That's why I ask
you about garage sales.
So anyway the reason why you don't want to
write a book is you still
got a couple moves in you
and you don't want to put it out there
because that's how you're
gonna fuckin' do it.
- [Tilman] Right but
so they just wanted it
and say talk about how you made it.
What were your philosophies,
all your tilmanisms and the 95/5 rule.
95% of everything we do is
right everyday in business,
but look for the 5% you do wrong
and that's what makes you
better than everybody else.
There are no spare customers, okay?
It's a competitive world in
every one of our businesses.
Take no out of your damn vocabulary.
You're on a business trip and it's 11:02,
you hang up the phone on a call,
and you called out to
order some breakfast,
and they say I'm sorry sir we
don't serve breakfast anymore.
I say that's okay no problem
I don't need a waffle
or an eggs Benedict.
Just throw a couple eggs
in a skillet scrambled,
however it's easiest for you to do.
I'm sorry sir we don't serve breakfast.
Why are you telling me no?
I didn't ask you for anything special.
You're gonna throw a burger in the pan.
Just throw me a couple of
eggs and take care of me.
You're in the hospitality business, okay?
And you're telling me no.
And everybody's in the
hospitality business
no matter what they do.
You take care of your customer, okay?
You take care of your customers.
It's no different than we walk in,
your people meet us, polite,
put a welcome up on the screen,
you come in here,
everybody couldn't be can I
get you some water, Tilman?
Can I do this for you?
You're in the service business!
So why do you want to be an ass
and say no to somebody
when it's just as easy
to say yes or just give an alternative.
- [Gary] Tilman, because the company
is being run by somebody who's not.
'Cause these companies get big
and they hire somebody who
fuckin' went to Harvard
and fuckin' worked at Bain and McKinsey
and they don't know what the
fuck they're talking about.
That's why, Tilman.
- [Tilman] I loved my McKinsey consultants
when I see 'em.
I just love 'em.
It's so funny you said that
because I have in this book,
"Consultants will consult your
ass right out of business."
- [Gary] 100%.
- And I don't hire consultants.
- [Gary] You know why?
Because they've never
fuckin' done anything.
- [Tilman] Unless I need
a reporter or something,
and I tell 'em what I want 'em to say,
that's when I walk in.
- That's like me telling Russell Westbrook
what to fuckin' do.
- [Tilman] 100%.
- Stupid.
I watch a lot of basketball.
I've got ideas.
It's fuckin' stupid.
- 'Cause you know what you
know and what you don't know.
- [Gary] It's unbelievable.
It's why I love athletes.
When you really get to know
them it's really fascinating
how they talk about fans.
Whatever variable.
No matter how you take it,
pro and con.
If you melt every athlete,
what they really say when
they talk about fans is,
they just don't know.
Whether they say they're assholes
or whether they love them,
they just understand that
they have no fuckin' idea.
They have no context.
It's actually my favorite thing
that's going on on earth right now.
We live in a judgment society.
Because it's social and
everybody has a voice
and we've always been judgemental.
That's how humans are.
Small little town,
somebody says oh Ruth's
borsch is not as good.
Like, we've always been
judgemental, right?
But now we can see the
physical manifestation of it.
But the reality is,
people are judging people left and right
without knowing anything about the truth.
Nobody knows you.
- [Tilman] Nobody.
And that's why when I have a good friend
that'll say to me,
I was over here and I was at a bar
and they were trashing your ass,
and I'll say to them,
well do you know Tilman Fertitta?
No but that's what I heard.
Because people don't like people on top.
And you're on top,
I'm on top,
and I do think people though
are getting a little nicer though.
I think people now seem to
respect you or whatever.
- [Gary] Listen we have
macro anxiety in ecosystem
and eventually that becomes tiring
and people go the world
just ebbs and flows.
It's not super complicated.
Tilman so I like this story,
'cause I wanna go back
'cause I like learning
from storytelling and you're
doing a great job at it.
You don't have to pay
back for an extra five,
that gives you ammo,
you have all these great brands,
so I'm really excited to dig
in here for a little bit.
By the way my entire company,
which we're a global marketing company,
a thousand people,
big business,
it's all a front.
I'm building all this infrastructure
to do what you and I do at scale,
which is when the economy collapses,
I'm gonna buy historic brands
and refurbish them.
- [Tilman] And that's what I do.
And I was the first person out there
to start a platform in saying,
let me give you an example.
So I go public in 1993.
- [Gary] With what?
- [Tilman] With 10 restaurants.
- Which ones?
- [Tilman] Landry's Seafood House.
I'm making $6 million a year in EBITDA
and all of the sudden you wake up
and you're on the Nasdaq and
you're worth $100 million.
So over the next few
years I built restaurants.
Then we hit a dip in the late 90's.
- [Gary] Why?
- The tech dip.
- [Gary] You mean the market?
- [Tilman] The market did.
- [Gary] Your stock price went down.
- Yes.
- [Gary] I understand.
Was your business healthy though?
- [Tilman] My business was healthy
and you know this,
what your stock does...
- Has nothing to do, nothing.
- [Tilman] Has nothing
to do with each other.
- Can I ask a question?
Tilman wait a minute.
This is actually
completely confusing to me.
You were a public CEO?
- [Tilman] Yes.
For 18 years.
- How the fuck did you
deal with that shit?
- Because I performed and...
- [Gary] You told them
to go fuck themselves?
You had to a little bit, right?
You had to tell these
people on the earning call
who would try to ticky
tack you on some bullshit.
- [Tilman] The longer I
got and the richer I got
I put up with less, okay?
You got to remember...
- [Gary] Leverage is a funny thing.
- [Tilman] No but it's
interesting because...
- You had a board that was all in on you?
- [Tilman] Let me,
first off when I took
it public I owned 100%.
- [Gary] That's an easy way to start.
- So it was my board.
I had a board but it was my board.
And if you keep over 50%,
you only have to have an
outside audit committee.
You don't even have to
have an outside board.
So you don't have to have a
compensation committee and all that.
- [Gary] I understand.
- So I basically
controlled the company for
many many years but I
grew it from a $30 million
company to when I took it private,
being an opportunist x
amount of years later,
to a multi billion dollar company.
But we got off track somewhere.
But what happened is I realized that
I could go buy somebody
and get rid of their GNA
and bring them to Houston
and keep the store operations
but not have all that overhead.
And so over the next...
- [Gary] That was arbitrage.
- Because over the next
20 years what I did was,
and I can tell you every
city that I shut down
somebody from Portland,
McCormick, & Schmidt
to Chicago Chart House's
home offices were there.
And Martin's home offices were there.
And Laguna Beach, it was
Bubba Gump and Claim Jumper.
And I can just go from city to city.
Minneapolis, it was
Oceanaire and Rainforest.
So I bought all these companies
and I just shut their office down
and consolidate in Houston
and save millions and millions on GNA.
And so I built this platform
and I bought all these companies, right?
And rejuvenated them if they needed it.
Some of them weren't even screwed up.
They were just screwed
up public companies.
But I bought Rainforest for $75 million
and it was making $30 million a year
and $15 million in the bank.
But their stock had fallen
'cause their gross slowed down.
But it was a great company to buy.
And back then everybody else was scared.
Private equity hadn't gotten into
consumer businesses yet
and people that are
strategic wouldn't buy 'em
because oh I'm a CEO
they might fire my ass
if I screw up.
Well I said fuck this
I'll go buy the world.
And took my networth from
a few hundred million
to billions.
- [Gary] Yup.
Then what happened?
- Better keep going mother fucker, okay?
(laughter)
- So you built that up,
you built that up,
you built that up.
- [Tilman] But then in ten,
well a lot of 'em happened after ten.
But in '08 and '09 when the crisis,
every stock went down,
I went back and bought
100% of my company again.
- [Gary] 'Cause you were liquid enough?
- I was liquid enough and knew how to
financially engineer it
and today it's probably
truly the single largest
one share holder company in America.
Everybody's got a 1%
partner or this or that.
It is 100% me and my family.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- Four billion in revenue,
seven hundred million EBITDA.
- Fuckin' amazing.
- [Tilman] So it's been a good ride.
- So you're still actively running it?
- [Tilman] Fuck yeah.
Who else is gonna run it?
- [Gary] I don't know.
Oh you said yes 18 years
you took a private,
listen I don't know shit about you!
- [Tilman] Obviously.
- I mean I know you're fuckin'...
- You better go read my fuckin' book.
- [Gary] I don't read shit.
(laughter)
Did you read my fuckin' report card?
Tilman talk to me about this.
Are you paying attention to
the potential disruption,
this is probably something
that's on your radar,
by the way at some point we'll have dinner
I can feel it already and I
really need you to tell me
the war stories about the video game.
- [Tilman] I will tell you that.
All them quarters in my pocket.
- I love that shit.
But are you paying attention
to these virtual kitchens?
Because I'm very fast,
this is early for me,
you're much deeper expertise,
but I think Fast Casual and QSR
have a looming potential concern
very similar to the
way I felt about retail
ten years ago around
these virtual kitchens
and people building brands
on top of that infrastructure
and actually just being
marketing companies and doing
last mile delivery at scale,
in a decade,
is this on your mind?
- I see all of it and I
think about all of it.
But food to me is still a personal thing.
And I just don't think.
- [Gary] Personal as
in you'll go somewhere?
- [Tilman] Yes in how you
eat it and who prepared it
or whatever so I don't know
that the virtual kitchen
is it ever gonna work.
- So you're saying,
from maybe from a fast food
drive in infrastructure
that will disrupt it
because that's a mobile play
but things that go a little bit higher up
where you're actually going to it...
- [Tilman] People are always like it
if it helps you quicker.
You know technologies speed winds.
But I still think that you still want to
touch and feel at the same time.
- Hold on let's keep playing this
'cause I'm fascinated by your take.
Touch and feel as in I
have to go to the place?
- [Tilman] Go to the place.
- [Gary] That I believe.
But I think on the delivery front
it's gonna be a fascinating debate.
- [Tilman] There is a
delivery issue though.
And this is the problem.
You've got all the home
delivery companies.
- [Gary] They're all under water.
- They're all under water.
I invested in one
and now I'm under water.
Matter of fact I'm drowning.
(laughter)
- [Tilman] I'm not drowning,
I drowned.
- [Gary] Yeah you're dead.
We went to the funeral it was amazing.
- 'Cause the problem is
is that it's expensive
because of labor cost today
and fuel cost and everything else and then
the delivery companies want a 20% discount
at least or a little more a little less.
The restaurants don't make any money then
because that's our margin.
So they're not happy,
we're not happy.
So I really don't know where it's going
if you want to know the truth.
- That I agree with.
Because the drivers aren't winning,
the restaurants aren't winning,
the platforms are not winning.
That's dead.
I think that the next step
that's being built quietly
right now which is the
infrastructure to make the food
at scale within one mile
radius of an enormous
percentage of our society
is gonna be a totally different game.
- I will totally,
once again we all come
up with great ideas,
this is gonna work.
Blue Apron,
people are never gonna
go out to dinner again,
they're gonna fix this.
- [Gary] Let me ask this.
This is just a fun thing
'cause in ten years
we'll watch this video
we'll get a kick because,
by the way what I know about you
because I'm listening
for sure is 99% of people
don't play the way we play
because they're scared to lose.
- [Tilman] No fear.
- [Gary] I love losing.
I mean it.
I actually mean it because
that means I fucked up.
I deserve it.
I never blame anything else.
I did something wrong.
Full fuckin' accountability.
Nonetheless do you agree
with this statement
because I think you may not
which is amazing,
I believe that in a decade
there will be a restaurant
that looks like Shake Shack
that looks like Chick Fil A
that looks like Fast Casual or QSR
that actually has no locations
but is a billion dollar
enterprise in sales
of their product on the
framework of these kitchens
at scale around the world.
True or false?
- Possibly could happen.
- [Gary] That's not an answer.
True or false?
- [Tilman] False.
- Awesome.
Now we have a fun dinner it ten years.
Now we have a fun dinner.
- No 'cause I have so
many brands in Houston.
I thought about building just one kitchen
and let everything go out of there.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Okay but then your delivery pie
is only gonna be so big.
- Yeah unless you hit
infrastructure at scale.
Listen I gotta run because
I have a public appearance.
But I'm fuckin' pissed because
we haven't even started.
So we need to hack this.
How often are you in Houston?
Always?
- No I have a place here in New York also.
I'm up here at least once a month.
- [Gary] Are you willing to
do part two with me on this?
- [Tilman] Absolutely.
- Is the book out?
- The book came out yesterday.
You can order it on Amazon.
- [Gary] Every single
person that's watching,
buy this book.
- [Tilman] "Shut Up and Listen".
- [Gary] "Shut Up and Listen".
- (laughs) And what's
better than you get that
more than anybody right Gary?
- [Gary] You know what's funny?
No because,
you mean I get it from people saying that?
- [Tilman] No you get it
because you want people
to listen because you know
you have something to say.
- [Gary] You know what's funny, Tilman?
I'll be very frank with you.
This is interesting to me.
You know what my title would be like?
Hey I hope you listen
because if you'd actually
do something with what I'm saying,
something good might happen.
What?
- [Tilman] That's long-ass title.
If they're gonna sell that mother fucker.
He was dyslexic.
(laughter)
- For all the things, Tilman,
that I think have gone well what have you,
you really won me over
on the eggs at 11:04.
For some weird reason no
matter what I accomplish,
and I fuckin' plan on accomplishing,
there's something about the consumer
that I just respect so uncomfortably more
than what I want for myself
that it makes me go there.
I don't feel all my accomplishments
or all the predictions and invest,
all the things I've been right about
still to this day I think I have to earn a
hey please consider, you know?
And I love where you went with it.
I know where you went with it.
But my big thing is the prayer that they
do something with it.
Tilman, do you know how many people
are watching or listening
to this right now
who've come across you over the last
30 or 40 years who had the
luxury of being in a meeting
or dinner with you where
you said something smart,
they built on top of it,
they knew what to do but they
didn't do anything about it?
- [Tilman] No but people tell me,
I know this I had to learn this,
we're just talking
words but people listen.
- [Gary] Yeah listen.
That I understand.
What I'm talking about is
for example I'm gonna tell you right now
that you should but a shitload of
Wilt Chamberlain, Oscar Robertson,
that the legends of the NBA
are on the beginning
phases of being similar
to the Marvel Universe
and some of the most iconic '60s and '70s
and even early '80s rookie
cards are about to TEDx.
I know that to be true.
- Hey don't tell everybody that are
listening to us, Gary.
- [Gary] Tilman you
wanna know the best part
of why I keep doing this?
Nobody takes fuckin' action.
- [Tilman] (laughs) Well
I'm gonna take some action.
- Yes sir.
- All right ya'll cancel my next meeting.
(laughter)
Come see a basketball
game with me in Houston.